Camille Feireisen.
- Chez le créateur de mode
les couleurs et les formes
fluidemarque de
fabrique. Son entreprise,
L'Uomo Strano, propose des
non genrés.
"Je voulais que les personnes
non binaires puissent avoir
une garde-robe qui leur
ressemble, au-delà des idées
les hommes et les femmes
doivent chacun porter."
Pour des personnes non binaires
comme Dani, casser ces bartant.
Mais aussi éviter
des re
Pendant 20 ans,
l'enseun homme à contrecoeur.
C'est la pandémie qui lui
a donné le coup de pouce
pour oser porter les vêtements
t de voir que
de plus en plus de créateurs
confectionnent des collections
non genrées. Ces changements
de menchez les étudiants
en design de la mode.
PHILIPPE DENIS, chargé de cours,
École de mode à l'UQAM
rupture entre un monde qui est
davantage axé par ses valeurs...
à l'ancienne société, en
cette société bourgeoise qui,
encore à exister, et cette
nouvelle génération qui te
mine de rien, de justement
faire bouger lesde créer finaleé
qui lege.
- Après tout, dit-il, la mode
est un
et le vêtement en est
l'un d.
Ici Camille Feireisen,